terminó la octava conferencia y lo hizo
con 341 compromisos para proteger los
océanos por montos que ascienden a los
19,978 millones de dólares hay tres
hechos a destacar el primero es que
Panamá se posesiona como líder Ambiental
de la región primero porque amplió un
área Marina protegida que de aquí a que
lo logren tres años alcanzará a
salvaguardar el 54% de su zona económica
exclusiva y por otro lado avanzó en su
lucha contra los plásticos desde antes
este había sido el primer país
centroamericano en prohibir las bolsas
plásticas y ahora se comprometió a otros
hitos uno de ellos por ejemplo es
eliminar totalmente los plásticos de un
solo uso en los próximos tres años y
reducir en un 30% los envases plásticos
que importan e incrementar este
porcentaje un 50% en la próxima década
otro de los hechos relevantes es que
John Carrey definitivamente
uno de los diplomáticos ambientales
Primero aquí hizo anuncios para proteger
los océanos que duplican el valor que
las agencias estadounidenses prometieron
en el Ocean del año pasado por otra
parte anunció los primeros proyectos del
corredor marítimo verde que tiene con
Panamá y fiji y aquí había llegado desde
antes Donde había ido a Brasil también
para debatir temas ambientales Y por
último Panamá Le entregó el evento a
Grecia donde será el agua Ocean de 2024